listen and listen well because no truer
words are ever going to be spoken
you can do anything you want without
limitation whatever it is that you
decide you want to make come true in
your life you can do that it is going to
take an inhuman amount of work you're
going to have to be prepared to break
yourself in half you're going to have to
learn more than anyone has ever learned
you're going to have to push yourself
harder than anyone has ever asked you to
push yourself before you're going to go
way beyond your breaking point you're
going to run until you vomit you're
going to study until you fall asleep
you're going to push and push and push
and then you're going to push
more and when you hit the limit you're
going to push again beyond that you're
going to force yourself into an
adaptation response and why
because as malcolm x said
the future belongs to those who prepare
for it today
so if you don't put the work in today
if you don't do
the unending back breaking work of
developing yourself into something
greater the world is going to pass you
by the people that are going to own it
are going to be the ones that did that
work and the one promise that i can make
you right now is that somebody
somebody out there is out working
somebody right now
is doing the things that i'm saying
somebody right now
is doing the work of failing and getting
up and getting better and pushing
themselves and triggering that glorious
adaptation response that makes humans
the apex predator someone right now
they're putting in that work
and if you don't
the future is going to belong to them
and as martin luther king jr said
if you can't fly then run
if you can't run then walk if you can't
walk then crawl but whatever you do
you have to keep moving forward
it's not okay to make excuses it's not
gonna slow people down it's not okay to
ask the world to stop so that you can
step out front it's not okay to expect
little of yourself and
demand great rewards the only thing
that's okay is to be in line with the
way that the world really works and if
you want to be great you've got to
become capable of greatness you've got
to develop your skill set you've got to
take what you have now and if that's
crawling then crawl but you drag
yourself ever forward to a vision of
yourself that is so clear and so
specific that nothing could knock you
off your path because you my friend know
exactly where you're going you're
willing to pay whatever price it takes
to get there and no matter what anybody
says no matter how many hecklers come
for you no matter how many people try to
throw dirt on you try to stop them try
to knock you down no matter how many
people come for you at night while you
sleep you will rise and you will keep
pushing forward and you will get better
every day and no matter how many times
people chop at you knock you down knock
you off the path you will get back on
you will crawl till you can walk you
will walk till you run and then you will
run until you fly and that my friends is
the only path forward so if you want a
future that makes you happy if you want
a world that you're excited about get
your ass out there and earn it
want to be happy build a life not just
the business hey it's evan carl michael
and this channel is created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how you
can achieve your most ambitious goals
enjoy
rule number two pay the switch cost with
john assaraf that conscious effort to
change a behavior
makes us uncomfortable even though it
may be good for us it makes us
uncomfortable for a day seven days 20
days 30 days
that period of time
is what we call as the switch cost
and if people understand that you've got
to do something for about 66 days not 20
days not 40 but the latest research says
that to
to make the switch cost stick
commit to at least 66 days
and your brain will then take what you
have to consciously think about what you
constantly have to put effort towards
doing it'll make it automatic so you
don't have to think about it anymore
that and so the first part is whatever
goal you want to achieve first ask
yourself am i prepared
to pay the switch cost
to be uncomfortable
long enough to make my new thoughts my
new emotions and my new behaviors
the default the new default yes because
once it's like the browser that's set on
your computer it's the automatic it's
automatic yes and if you think about our
lives most of what we do is automatic we
don't deviate very much from when we
wake up when we go to sleep what we
watch what we eat where we exercise who
we hang out what clothes do we wear
we're pretty much creatures of habit yes
the key is
most of the habits that people have i'm
referring to habits as emotions thoughts
and behaviors right are geared towards
helping you achieve exactly what you are
achieving right now and
for those of you that don't think
that you are committed you are to those
results yes to those who don't think you
are disciplined yes you are to those
thoughts and feelings and behaviors
right the key is to become committed
more committed
to your new vision whether it's your
body your relationship your health your
business
and then pay the switch costs long
enough to make that
the new you rule number three structure
your life properly with jordan peterson
the other thing you should do if you're
not very industrious
industrious is discipline yourself and
so what do you do with that
eat three times a day at regular meal
times that's a good thing to practice
because that starts to put some
stability into your life get up at the
same time i would highly recommend all
those young people out there who are
listening like you want to get a jump on
life get the hell out of bed in the
morning you know as i've got older i've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because i've
got more and more discipline
like get up early in the morning and get
your things done man learn to get up at
six in the morning and you'll be one
deadly creature especially if you can
get to work you'll have half your damn
day done by the time other people haul
their sorry asses out of bed and so
that's a massive massive advantage look
will ferrell
warren farrell not the comedian warren
farrell the author he outlined data in
why men earn more which is a book i
would recommend by the way showing that
if you work 13 longer hours you make 40
more money
it's non-linear so you think why is that
well imagine you had 10 employees and
one of them works an extra 10 percent
it's not much
well how often is that person going to
be
promoted assuming you have a clue as a
boss
it's like you're going to look at the 10
people and you're going to think oh that
guy's always here like 45 minutes early
it's like why don't we give him the
promotion obviously right so these tie
these small edges that you can manage
like that work an extra 10 or extra 13
percent have non-proportional payoffs
that's part of the pareto distribution
so
get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses i'm too tired in the morning
i don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it schedule
your meals because that's a good
disciplinary routine
and then learn to use a calendar like
google calendar most of you many of you
out there do not use a calendar okay a
calendar is not a prison and it's not a
tyrant not if you use it properly
a calendar keeps anxiety at bay it makes
sure that you do what you need to do
which is important because otherwise you
fall behind but if you use it properly
though it's also
helps you plan what you want to do so i
could say well lay out your damn
calendar
and
design the days you would like to have
that's what your calendar is for so you
can put in all sorts of things in there
you want to do and that would be good
for you and that's a really good
really good way to start being more
industrious
make a plan you need a plan for three
years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months you
need to plan for the next three months
you need a plan for the week you need a
plan for the day you need to plan for
the hour
all of that all of that i make lists
constantly of what i have to do and
they're like daily weekly monthly yearly
right now i can't look out more than
about six months you know because my
life is too complicated and chaotic but
but you need a vision of who you could
be what character you could have three
to five years out you can't go much
farther than that because life is too
unpredictable i think to
make vision that's longer term than that
subject to
there's too much chance associated with
it to spend a lot of time on maybe you
can stretch it to five years and in rare
cases you can have a 10-year goal but it
has to be pretty low resolution but you
want plans at all those levels of
resolution you want to write the things
down
and what because what are you going to
do you're going to stumble around and
get get what you need you're going to
stumble around and be useful to other
people and it's useful to be useful to
other people you know they want to work
with you then they want to do things
with you they want to have you around
they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer and then you're going to
be bitter and then you're going to be
cruel so that's a that's hell that's a
bad outcome
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four get up early with
robin sharma the key thing super
producers do
the best of the best
they get up early
so
here's what i wanted to share with you i
wanted to literally deconstruct the 5
a.m club concept which is just you get
up at five o'clock you give yourself one
hour in the greatness guide i call it
the holy hour which you're not in the
world you're not checking your
notifications you're not anywhere near
technology you're not watching the news
you're not chit chatting you're not
daydreaming you are literally running a
one hour period of practice to set up
your mindset your heart set your health
set your soul set the four interior
empires that i teach at personal mastery
academy
so that by six o'clock
you feel fundamentally different now you
might be saying robin
what
5 a.m
well if you're feeling that any good
idea is going to disrupt you any new
idea will shake you up a little bit and
so if you're feeling i couldn't do that
if your mind is full of chatter on
excuses if you say you know robin i
can't win the battle of bed i can't put
mind over mattress
my father couldn't get up early mum
couldn't get up early grandpa used to
sleep in i just don't have the genetics
to allow me to get up early
yes you do we know from the research of
university college london
that it takes 66 days to wire in
neurobiology
a new habit 66 days and as you know from
my brain tattoo that is very well known
all change is hard at first if it wasn't
hard at first to get up early it
wouldn't be valuable change and it's
messy in the middle and it's beautiful
at the end
so if you want to get up early if you
want to have a gargantuan competitive
advantage if you want to have a massive
opportunity because most people
they might have great products they
might have a great mindset they might be
great entrepreneurs or great performers
they might be working at a great company
they might have a corporate culture that
is fantastic
but most people on the planet will never
get up at 5am and that's why it is a
gargantuan competitive advantage for you
the rest of the world is pretty much
sleeping those of us who love getting up
at five o'clock we know it's the
quietest time of the day
imagine this having one hour from five
to six
just for yourself
imagine one hour
where there's such a stillness in the
air where you can actually breathe and
think and be
and the spartan warriors say it so well
and this if you're interested in this
concept
the book is that i've written is the 5
a.m club and one of the lines i use
comes from the spartan warrior credo and
the spartans those great warriors here's
what they used to say
the one who
sweats more in training
bleeds less in war
and so
five to six your holy hour is simply
it's a training practice it's a training
ground like the great warriors so that
when you go out in the world you bleed a
lot less you have a lot more focus a lot
more energy you're focused on your
priorities and your values versus
society's priorities and their values
and you know what i want to say to you
some days i get up at 4 45 to start my 5
a.m protocol and i feel exhausted and i
don't want to do it
and i say
why have i been teaching this 5am club
concept for so many years to the leaders
i work with and the people who come to
the titan summit you know and people
like richard branson have been on my
stage and steve wozniak the co-founder
of apple and shaquille o'neal was in the
room at the titan summit a number of
years ago and why do i teach this and
why do i teach the protocol well here's
the key
not only will it fundamentally change
the way your days play out but the way
you feel at six
is very different from the way you feel
when you first wake up so
give yourself 66 days please understand
that getting up early is a gargantuan
competitive advantage and it will be the
single best thing or certainly one of
the single best daily habits that you
could possibly install in your life if
you're seriously interested in legendary
leadership being a world builder and a
history maker rule number five visualize
daily with brendan burchard be honest is
there anything in the last let's say six
months that you had as a goal
and then you literally just forgot about
you're like oh i forgot i was trying to
lose that weight yes please bring the
chow mein right you just forgot and you
didn't mean to forget see most people
think it's well maybe i didn't really
want it or maybe it's a prioritization
thing i'm like no it's just that
sometimes when we lose touch with what
we want because we're not putting it in
front of us often enough
we move on to the next thing that's you
know a fire drill or a challenge or
trouble and the good things that we
wanted the great goals that we set up
fall by the wayside so how can you
prevent that bring back your
visualization practice
you know when you first had that goal or
that dream that big desire i bet you sat
in bed and you thought about it and you
dreamed about it and you could
practically taste it you wanted it so
bad you know you could see it in your
dreams during the day if you talk to
other people about it it felt real
it was a goal you were going to go after
and it just it showed up in your dreams
it showed up when you closed your eyes
it showed up when you talk to other
people that's a real fire goal that's a
good one right
and yet what happens when people often
set a goal they open up their calendar
they schedule it or they open up a work
plan and they say okay to achieve goal i
must you know measure it this way and i
must set this date and i must do all
these things and they tactically fill
out their calendar or fill up their day
planner and it sounds like it's going to
happen right but it doesn't
it's because look you could have lots of
to-do's all over your calendar but never
feel like really going for the goal and
that's because
you're not emotionally charging yourself
up for that goal on a continual basis
that's why it falls aside so quickly
because you got really excited about it
but then oh this other thing i'm excited
about and there's another thing i
consider and now you're just running
around like you've got like super
massive add which i totally understand
so here's what you have to do is what
you have to do you have to set up a
visualization practice that is daily
here's the simplest technique for you if
you're not already doing it when you
wake up in the morning each morning
before you even go to bed just wake up
as soon as you awake take a nice couple
deep breaths close your eyes and
visualize yourself
striving for your goals
struggling for your goals
then attaining your goals okay so what i
mean literally imagine like for me i'm
an author as you know right i write
books so i sit i'll sit there and i'll
think okay i can see myself writing at
the desk today okay now oh i see myself
not riding at the desk today the
struggle i've gone off and i'm wandering
around the park convincing myself that
this is what i must do to find some
creativity stop that no
the most important part about
visualization is not to see yourself
cross the finish line it's to see what
do you do
when the struggle happens
to maintain
right so if you want to run a marathon
as an example lots of people say well
visualize yourself running across the
marathon line visualize that visualize
that visual i'm like actually no
visualize yourself getting up
for months and months and months going
for those morning runs practicing
visualize yourself when you are running
the marathon right in the middle of a
marathon when you're at let's say well
let's say you're at like mile 13 you
know and you're just like oh my gosh
i can't possibly do any more
visualize yourself overcoming
that struggle
that's where an emotional sort of anchor
sets in for making a goal important when
not only do you visualize yourself doing
it but struggling through to make it
happen then yes visualize yourself
running across that finish line i
visualize myself opening up that box of
books when my publisher first sends me
the first draft finally manuscript
finally published when i open up that
box and i get that first book and i'm
like this is real
you know that's my moment like it's real
so i'll lay in bed visualizing that not
kidding and i don't do it once not twice
not three times i've been doing that
visualization technique for the last six
months as i'm trying to finish my next
book so i'm not just talking about this
conceptual i do this in my own life and
i encourage you do that if you keep
having goals that fall off on the
wayside or fall on the back burner it's
because you're not revisiting them you
need to revisit it
visualize it see it right really make it
a visual thing tell the story see it in
your mind rule number six attach
emotions to your goals with dean
graziosi right now is a time to revisit
the emotions right now is a time to look
at those goals and say how will i feel
in six months if i achieve these
visualize it don't just say how will i
feel in the future put yourself six
months from right now and literally sit
and feel is it your weight how will you
look in the mirror how do you feel when
you walk in a room is it finally
quitting a job that's killing it how
will it feel to be a little nervous but
be independent working on your own thing
register that url make the first sale
make the first call looking at your
husband your wife and knowing your
confidence visualize six months from now
if those
goals are achieved how will you feel no
change happens unless there's an emotion
attached to it nothing is memorable
unless you have a feeling i mean think
about this i'm going to digress for a
minute think about your childhood think
about those moments that you remember
when you were 3 6 9 12. it was either
the home run you hit in little league or
softball or the day your parents got
divorced or it was when you got accepted
to the baseball team or you got cut from
the baseball team you remember those
because there's a feeling there's an
emotion attached to them and they
exponentially stick like they they that
maybe not exponentially like they
exponentially grow but
they stick to you and rule number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is write down your goals
with marissa peer when you have a goal
in your head it's not even a goal it's a
fantasy
it's a dream
when you have a book like this you can
call it your goal book and you write out
your goals and you go through i'm just
about to take you through bit by bit
stage by stage you go back to that but
you can look at it you can touch it you
can just make it real so remember if you
do not write out your goals as a plan
and write out how to accomplish them you
didn't have a goal you have a wish you
have a dream you have a daydream
if you want to go get a pen get a nice
little book like this you can do on your
phone too you can make a document in
your computer
and be prepared to make your goals real
so let's
start now
get your book pause this if you need to
go and find one create one
and i want you to pick a goal and do not
even start with i want to lose five
pounds i want more money these are what
i call wishy
washy goals no
if you can make your goals real you
might as well make them huge big
enormous phenomenal so if you say well i
want more money that's my luggage oh
hang on a minute
hey i've got ten dollars here there you
go you go well that's not my goal but
you said
i want more money and i learned this
when i used to work with women who were
infertile that come and go you know i
just want to be pregnant i want to be
pregnant so bad
if i was just pregnant i go well
as i look at your notes you've been
pregnant six times i know i keep
miscarrying
so being pregnant is not your goal is it
what
isn't your goal to carry to full term a
healthy robust bouncing baby to deliver
a perfect baby to be a great mum yeah
that's my goal
why don't you say that
because you can be pregnant lots of
times and never have a baby or you can
say my goal
is to have a perfect baby how about this
my goal is to get lots of attention for
what
a nervous twitch
explosive gas that will give you
attention but that's not what you want
is it nobody wants explosive gas
so let's start with a big goal pause if
you need to
take some time open your book
and write out a big goal now you can
have a career goal on whatever i'm going
to have my own company create my own
business invent something you can have a
relationship go my relationship is
wonderful we grow
in loving and respecting each other and
you can have a health goal
but i want you to pick one only one not
three not five not in one goal it can be
career
it can be health
it can be love pick one goal
and then
i want you to decide why you want that
goal so much so the first thing is i
have a goal
i want to have my own business that's my
goal and now you're going to go to a
next page and write out why
do you want to have your own business so
much and the more reasoned you can write
out why the more likely
you will make that goal real so write
down why write down as many wise as you
can and remember
you can come back any time to this and
think ah i've thought of another y and
another y so leave plenty of space
take your time and when you've done your
y's go to another page and write out
who
will benefit from you achieving that
goal of course you will but who
who will benefit for instance if you
have your own business
you will employ people who will benefit
maybe your kids will go to private
school maybe your business will allow
you to help your partner have their
business
the more people who will benefit from
you achieving your goal
the more reasons you have
to achieve that goal so write out who
will benefit from you
achieving a who
how and why will they benefit you're
going to buy
your mama house put your niece and
nephew through private school did you
think of your mind as like the genie
in the bottle that says your wish is my
command
and i want you to understand that every
thought you think and every word you say
is a blueprint that your mind body and
psyche must make real so when you write
out your goals don't say i wish
i could be rich
i long to be in a loving relationship
write it as if it's already happening i
am
a millionaire i am in a loving
relationship like well that doesn't make
sense it does make sense because your
mind only works in the present tense
when you say next year i'll have a
bikini body it doesn't know what next
year is
and so you must write your goals in the
present tense i am i always i have i do
this new page is about your discipline
how many hours a day are you going to
spend
working on your goal
how often are you going to come back to
this book and look at it i want you to
write out i
am
i
always i have i do and i want you to
fill that in
you see the best goal in the world will
not work if you don't work and many
people fail at this point they write out
a goal my goal is to be
a millionaire my goal is to be famous my
goal is to be wildly in love and i think
that's it
it's not it if you want to be madly in
love
write all the reasons why but then you
have got to
put yourself in front of the kind of
person you want to share your life with
if you want to start your own business
and you have a reason why you also need
to have the discipline to meet people
who will fund you
sponsor you joint venture with you
so i want you to really understand that
the best goal will not work if you don't
work you can have the start point
but you have to keep doing many of the
most successes we will ever say well you
know i had a goal
luther vandross had a goal
to be a rock star
and people said well you're an overnight
success he went i don't think so you
know i sang jingles for kfc for 12 years
that's a long night 12 years and people
said but luther you're singing on
television that's cool you get paid a
lot of money for kfc he said yeah but
it's not my
and he stuck it out and many people have
got so close to success
and had to keep going and you have to
keep going so
look at your discipline and decide you
will give more to your goal give even
more
work on it look at it write it out think
about it talk about it you must be
prepared to give so much to your goal
in fact you must be prepared to be
unstoppable in the pursuit of your goal
the number one way to deal with negative
people in your life is through empathy
it's empathy it's not it's not hating
them back it's not spreading negativity
it's not reminding yourself that you're
better than them it's it's empathy
and it's not even just feeling bad for
them
it's actually connecting to them
let me let me explain
i default assuming that people are good
this is a wild idea
people are good humans are good i've
done the who exercise the year one word
exercise helping people find the most
important core value with so many people
and
it's always something positive
i believe that
99.9999999 percent of people are good
there's a tiny tiny tiny percentage of
people who enjoy killing people and
maybe have you know a few screws loose
up here but for the most part we're good
everybody has dreams everybody has
ambitions everybody wants to serve
everybody wants to be in a better place
than where they are right now
the problem is
a lot of people are afraid a lot of
people are in pain a lot of people are
struggling a lot of people are suffering
a lot of people have tried they took
their shot and it didn't work out and
because they're so in pain now they
don't want other people around them to
have success either
because if they took a shot and it
didn't work out
it's they don't want to own it that it's
on them but if you then go off and have
success you start achieving your goals
what does that say about them
right it's not that the world is rigged
against them is that they actually suck
and they don't want to admit that they
don't want to own up to that and so
they're living in pain
and so they take it out and other people
they take it out on you they take it out
on me they take it out on on the world
they take it out on people right that's
what that's what people do when they're
in a lot of pain think about you think
about your experiences your life think
about when you've been in a lot of pain
when you've struggled really think about
this the last time that you were
struggling in a lot of pain did you then
show up as your best self in all
situations
did you maybe lose your cool on somebody
did you maybe
insult somebody did you maybe say
something that you're not proud of that
you later would regret has it has that
ever happened to you
so that you're a bad person so that
you're a toxic person it's not that
you're a hater
you were just in a lot of pain
and so the people who are throwing shade
at you are in a lot of pain they're
struggling
and just recognizing that just trying to
put yourself in their shoes and look at
their life
and if you know them you can actually
look at their life and if you don't know
them you can assume things about their
life
if if somebody's coming to leave in a
negative comment on your youtube video
the fact that that is the highlight of
their day
speaks volumes about them
right if the best part of your day is
going to somebody's youtube channel
leaving some nasty comment that gets you
feeling good
you're in a lot of just imagine the pain
that that person's in imagine what their
life is like right now
and it's a bit of a mental exercise
because at the beginning
the natural reaction is to be defensive
like well no i'm not this and how could
you call me that
and
we want the people around to support us
and cheer us on and tell us that we're
doing the right thing so the natural
defense mechanism kicks in where
we say no i'm that's not that's not
right but if you take a breather you can
take a step back and you can just
try to have empathy try to put yourself
in their shoes try to see that they're
in a lot of pain
what it does is removes the sting from
the words it removes the venom from the
words
it doesn't get you to react
as emotionally it allows you to show up
more as your best self it's it's one of
the most valuable things you can start
to practice this is one of the things
that prevents people from creating
content from posting videos from sharing
their thoughts you've got a big mission
a message your story can change people's
lives you your story your story can
change people's lives it will change
people's lives and we're afraid to do it
because of how
people that we don't know or people that
we do know will judge us
we're afraid that we're going to get
negative comments and that's the reason
why you're not putting your message out
there we have to learn you have to learn
to stop getting in your own way and to
start
sharing
to start releasing to start living your
life the life that you want not somebody
else's version of it
people are going to judge you
it doesn't say anything about you
it talks about them their mental state
the pain that they're in the struggle
that they're in the suffering they're in
right now so step number one is have
empathy
empathy empathy empathy try to try to
put yourself in their shoes understand
the pain that they're going through
and and it removes the emotion from what
they're saying and how they're behaving
okay step number two is then is there
any validity in what they're saying
sometimes
there's actually some truth to what
they're saying even even if it's only
one percent truth if it's 99
negativity and one percent truth a lot
of times you know when a customer writes
in maybe they're really upset maybe
maybe they feel cheated maybe they feel
ripped off maybe they feel you didn't do
your job maybe they're maybe they got
cut off in traffic in a really bad mood
today right but maybe they're calling in
to cancel or they get a refund from you
maybe there's some validity in what
they're saying before we just write off
somebody and say you're a negative
person you're toxic i don't want you in
my life maybe there's actually some
truth they presented it very poorly the
packaging was terrible right the
packaging sucked but maybe there's some
validity in the message maybe there's
part truth that you can learn from and i
think this is really important because
if you can only learn from people who
package things really nicely who
sugarcoat everything who put in this
beautiful you know bow and say i love
you and you're amazing and keep doing
what you're doing and i have one little
tiny bit of feedback that maybe you
could learn from like maybe this one
little thing but i love you and you're
amazing like if that's the only way
that you can receive feedback you're
never going to get the feedback you need
to win sometimes people will rage on you
sometimes people will yell at you
sometimes people will be rude to you
sometimes people will call you names
sometimes people will freak out it's
going to happen
is there any truth right once you can
remove the sting because you have
empathy for them
now you can actually see what they're
saying and see which you can use what
you can digest and what is worth
digesting what you're just going to
discard
because there might be truth
buried somewhere inside of their words
that can make you better that can still
help you that can that can improve your
life and your situation your business
and where you're trying to go so step
number one remove the sting step number
two look for the truth if there is now
there may be some that is just negative
but don't just default to thinking
negative default to thinking maybe
there's a lesson i can learn here and
step number three is then just decide
can you still be around these people or
not this is especially when they're in
your life where they're friends with
their family the people you're seeing
you might have to disconnect for a while
you might have to
because you're not strong enough yet you
might have to
not be around them
because their words hurt too much still
you might have to go and build build
your muscle build your empathy muscle
muscle build your empathy and build your
empathy muscle say that 10 times fast
you might have to go build that muscle
and that means you you
spend less time with them or kick them
out of your life
ultimately though
what i see
leaders entrepreneurs you i think you're
a tree and i wrote about this in in my
book built to serve i think you're a
tree what does a tree do a tree breathes
in the carbon dioxide which
too much of for humans is poison we
breathe the trees will breathe it in
they'll eat it they'll grow from it and
then they'll spit out oxygen positivity
for the world i see that as part of our
role as leaders and as entrepreneurs is
to eat other people's negativity grow
from it get better from it and then spit
out more positivity more oxygen for the
world ultimately the people who are
negative in your life you have an
ability to influence them you have an
ability to help them see the positive
road not through your
advice but through your actions by you
going off and doing your thing
will inspire other people to want to
change their life as well whoever is
more confident wins and when you're
around
really negative people
if you are doubting your positivity
they're going to win they're going to
drag you down
but ultimately the goal is to get so
positive so optimistic so
so happy
that you pull them up
that you're more positive you're more
certain in your positivity than they are
certain in their negativity and you pull
them
towards making a better life decision
everything we talk about has to be
proven right everything i love that i
don't give you some i've read in a book
or something that i've read on instagram
the only things that we share are things
that are backed by science that have
been researched that we have seen
working in our own lives that we see
working for our audience and i think
that is critical because let's face it
anybody can put up
a
inspirational quote
you know that they've read from somebody
else anybody can tell you to you know be
positive or do this or put in the work
or hustle or whatever the hell it may be
at the end of the day
it's just talk yeah you have to know how
yeah and i also am you know somebody who
is a little bit cynical
so you know i'm sort of embarrassed that
i'm in self-help on some level because
it sounds stupid right you know i mean i
come from i i mean i i'm older than you
i'm almost 50. self-help had a really
bad name
20 years ago and i also am ivy league
yeah lawyer yeah and
i
um
am an entrepreneur
there's a lot of i mean there's a lot of
there's a lot of fake people out there
for sure i i
renting houses and ferraris and telling
you if you use their click funnel
strategy or whatever strategy that
you'll be rich like they are and yeah
you may and chase the money if it
energizes you but there's a lot of smoke
in there for many of us slowing down is
really scary but that's exactly what you
need to do
and so if you are always in a rush if
you feel like there's urgency in your
life if you move at a pace that makes
you feel panicked or rushed you've got a
million things to do and you think that
you're busy but you're not productive
the solution is not doing more it's
doing less it's not speeding up it's
actually slowing down because being busy
doesn't mean you're in control it means
you're being driven by this fear of
slowing down you're being driven by the
fear that when you slow down you're
going to have to confront
where you're at and you're going to have
to start doing the work and that be that
can be scary
but you take control of your life not by
speeding up everybody
but by slowing down you take control of
your life by removing distraction and
adding in focus you take control of your
life by being honest with yourself about
the things that you're filling your life
with that doesn't matter that makes you
so busy
and that also prevents you from finding
the 15 minutes that you need every day
to really find the courage to focus on
making your life a little bit better or
pushing something forward if you're
somebody who's guilty of being busy and
never having the time to do the thing
that really matters to you that your
heart's calling you to do or you never
have the time to do something to take
care of yourself i want you to find 15
minutes today
and i want you to slow down
whether you've always thought about
meditating and you've never done it
download the comm app
listen to it do one guided meditation go
for a walk for 15 minutes just a quiet
walk without your phone or with your
phone turned off have a cup of tea or
cup of top coffee and read something
listen to a podcast for 15 minutes
take a bath tonight something where you
experience the sensation of slowing down
because again busyness becomes a habit
and when it becomes a habit it becomes
an epidemic and when it becomes an
epidemic it will rob you of your ability
to take control of your life and at the
root cause of all of this is fear
just the fear of slowing down because
when you slow down and you start to
create priorities and you start to take
control
now you're responsible for what's
happening in your life
and you can no longer rely on just
complaining that you're busy
i think the most important thing i want
you to know is whatever it is that
you're dealing with right now
no matter how scary it is no matter how
overwhelming it is
or even if you're just bored with where
your life is or if you're super happy
i want you to know that you always have
the power to change your life because
you have the power to make a decision to
change how you think about something to
change how you treat the people around
you to draw boundaries and to make the
small changes that add up to absolutely
everything you gotta raise your own game
gotta raise your own game and so what is
the game that you play at work you gotta
get out of the head that it's all about
you
the best team members are always
thinking about how to make the team
better the best team members are loyal
to the team the best people to work with
are the ones that are in it together and
so in order for you
to get your toxic colleague to shift
behavior you gotta model it and here's
the interesting thing about the research
when people are working with co-workers
or on a team
where people collaborate and where you
have honest conversations
it creates what we call psychological
safety which basically just means i feel
safe working with you i know that if i
come to you with feedback you listen i
know that if i tell you how your
behavior is impacting me you'll actually
care i know that if you need help you'll
come to me and i know if i need help i
can come to you that's what
psychological safety means you're a safe
person and hopefully a fun person to
work with
so you've gotta model that that means
you gotta ask for support that means you
gotta have direct collabora or direct
conversations and it means you gotta
support your team members too and do you
realize
that when
you work with other people that do this
team members are 35 times more likely
to show visible commitment to your
success and they're 47 more likely when
you model it to work hard to build and
maintain your trust
so don't ever get resigned and thinking
that the way that you behave
won't impact how somebody else is
behaving around you one of the most
important things when you're in a
situation where the truth the facts are
that there is more on your plate than
one human being can effectively handle
on his or her own
there's a really important
moment where you have to surrender
to the chaos
that your life is for the next couple
weeks
things are going to change when summer
hits
but part of what i find personally
is that when i resist and i do resist
i resist what's actually happening when
that's not the way that i want things to
go
and so if you
start complaining or you start bringing
extra weight to all of the things that
are going on it's gonna
make it feel even more overwhelming
and if you can bring a sense of realism
to it so i call this and i think sean
anchors the one that came up with this
this this term
realistic optimism
realistic optimism is a really powerful
mindset because
you're not just putting a sunny spin
on a crappy situation
you're being realistic about where you
are in your life right now
and you are
still
maintaining an optimistic point of view
and what that means is that you when
you're an optimist you believe that your
actions and your thoughts matter
you believe that you can handle what's
on your plate you believe that based on
your thoughts and your actions you can
positively affect the outcome of
whatever it is that you're dealing with
whether it's being wildly overwhelmed
because you're a single parent or
terrified because you just got a scary
health diagnosis
or you're spinning because somebody just
told you they don't want to be in a
relationship with you anymore whatever
it is that you're facing that's making
you feel overwhelmed
first start with how important it is to
be a realistic optimist so there's a
surrendering to what's so but you're
going to stay very optimistic and
positive and know that everything that
you think and do is in your control and
that when you know that your behavior
matters it gives you a sense of
empowerment that's proven by research
super duper important it's also why
you can have a very hard life right now
and a very overwhelming life right now
and still be happy
because you know based on being a
realistic optimist that this period will
pass and you know that there are things
that you can think about and do that are
within your control often times when you
hit bottom you bounce
and that's where i think the power is
that you when the world feels upside
down you always have the power to make
it right when one chapter ends you
always have the power to write a new one
when you know you feel like nobody loves
you you have the power to learn how to
love yourself and if there's one thing
that covid 19 has done regardless of
whatever devastation it has caused in
your life is it has forced us all
to experience the great pause
and
i read that in a medium article and i
love that idea of a pause because i
think in 2020 our lives have gotten so
fast and so digital and
when you are forced to pause and get
present and to slow down
you are reminded
of what's actually important
and what's important is your health
what's important is your family and your
friends
what's important is whether or not you
are taking care of yourself and thinking
positive thoughts versus negative
thoughts the world gave us a gigantic
experiment
where we got to practice and get to
continue to practice the most important
skill in the planet which is emotional
resilience the ability to face hard
and actually be okay
the ability to face the uncertain
and redirect your attention on things
that you know
that are certain but as is the case in
life you're always going to be growing
and when you hit new chapters in your
life
it's really important to be deliberate
and mindful
about the people that you spend time
with and who you surround yourself with
does that mean you got to ditch your
high school friends absolutely not
but it might mean that you shouldn't
spend as much time
with them
it might mean that you should show up to
those friendships a little bit
differently and maybe they'll go a
little bit deeper and it definitely
means that based on where you are in
your life right now that you should get
more proactive about surrounding
yourself with a group of new friends or
current friends that are up to the same
kind of growth that you are why do you
think that is in human beings that
you know things are going bad we won't
change
if they're going good we won't change
but it's almost like we need a massive
breakdown near death experience divorce
covid for us to see clearly to start
changing
well there's a really simple answer
patterns
so the thing about all human beings is
that we are pattern
learning machines
and if you feel
stuck or broken i guarantee you while
you feel that way you're not you have a
pattern of behavior or a pattern of
thinking that is broken
and we
need
to be disrupted
because we love our patterns and even
people that i know like
even when we're
[Applause]
yeah so a lot of people like you may be
listening to lewis and i talking and you
grew up in a super chaotic household
maybe your parents argued all the time
maybe your dad or mom were in and out
maybe there was a lot of fighting maybe
there was actual abuse i don't know what
was going on but it was chaotic as hell
and so as an adult
you have vowed yourself you are not
going to repeat that pattern
but what ends up happening is because as
a little kid you observed witness
absorbed the pattern of chaos in your
nervous system
unless you go about the intentional work
of breaking the pattern of chaos
you will create it in your own life
because it's what's familiar
you won't understand why do i keep
dating these
why do i why do i go to these bosses
that treat me like crap because you
don't know
what it feels like
to be in a relationship with either a
boss or a romantic partner or a roommate
that is consistent because for the first
18 years of your life you lived in an
estate called when's the next shoe gonna
drop right and so wherever it is in your
life that something is broken there is a
pattern that you don't see yet that is
making you continue to stay in a broken
situation it's all that thinking that
overthinking that thinking too big
thinking big is about dreams thinking
big is about goals thinking big is about
your heart and your soul and figuring
out what you want then once you do that
and you think big and you see where
you're headed
boom you got to come back and you've got
to go brick by brick to make that vision
stick you've got to go brick by brick to
make the action stick you've got to go
brick by brick to lay that pathway
forward and to keep going and let me
tell you something i don't care how busy
you are i don't care how tired you are i
don't care how much there is to do to
make this big dream forward you have
time to lay one brick a day you really
do
you really do and this is the secret
everybody this is the secret to
everything it's to understanding that
there is no timeline to getting your
dreams done
all there is to do is to allow your
heart and soul to dream big
to see the path forward and then to pull
yourself into the moment every day and
have the discipline to be deliberate to
lay one brick on that path that's it and
to keep reminding yourself that
everything that you're learning on the
way as you lie bricks down and you move
forward a little at a time
is helping you build the path and there
will be times that you start to lay
bricks in this direction and you realize
whoa wait a minute i'm going over here
and my dream is over there i guess i
better lay bricks over here and head
back in the direction then you're gonna
go this way that's great because
everything that you learned over here
is going to be exactly what you needed
in order to be
doing what your big dream is having a
breakdown is one of the biggest things
on the planet because what you get is
you get a break from your own
and you can look
objectively at where you are and for the
first time
look ahead and say well what do i want
to go create and nine times out of ten
if you're discouraged right now if
you've got financial devastation if
you've if you're facing something that
is making this moment in time as hard
for you as life was for lewis and i in
2008 during the last recession
i beg you
ask yourself honestly if what you had is
actually what you wanted mm-hmm the
thing that you just lost that that job
that you bitched about all the time a
relationship that was bad to you yeah
yes or the friends you can't hang out
with because it's convenient and you
can't you're in court like actually ask
yourself if this is what you wanted or
were you just used to it
being used to something
louis i think is the biggest reason why
people don't change
i asked my mother i love my mother i
love my parents i've been married 51
years
which is a feat because they were my mom
was a teen mom but
uh i asked her once if she'd go to a
personal development seminar with me
what'd you say
are you [ __ ] kidding me
why would i want to change at my age wow
i might discover i hate my life
wow
i was like okay i'm just going to leave
that right there
all right
question nutrition and impact theory
were to go out of business tomorrow and
you were to lose all of your money and
material possessions what would you do
starting from scratch what are the first
things you would do in the first 90 days
oh god this is awesome okay so
what would i do
okay step number one
deal mourn so honestly like i i would i
would allow myself a period of morning
and i would define that now i'm not
going to stand still during the morning
period but i think the reality is you
have to okay who am i kidding i wouldn't
do that um i would defer my morning
i've been through something like this so
i know exactly what i would do i would
defer the morning and i would
immediately contact i would make a list
of all the people that were in the world
so unless i'm gonna i'm gonna assume for
a second that impact theory went out of
business um
for reasons other than that the
industry um i'll assume the industry
hasn't imploded that's a very weird way
of saying that um so i'm going to go to
the 10 people that i've already earned
credibility with that know what i'm
capable of that know how i think that
know my uh process that like me want to
be around me
and i'm going to go offer my services to
them and i'm going to ask for either no
money if at all possible if i can my
wife and i can sleep on somebody's couch
or something like that
and in fact i may send my wife to get a
job that at least make some money so
that we can eat so that i can then begin
going back into the industry and
delivering value i think it's the area
that i'm going to be able to deliver the
most value and i would aim to get equity
that's me so that people understand look
my business may have failed but here's
my vision here's where i think i can add
value i would go in and i would have
such a freakish level of detail for what
i'd be able to do for their company and
that i would be asking for equity equity
is a big thing for me so i wouldn't
worry so much about salary i would just
make sure that i was making enough to
eat i don't my ego isn't tied up in the
house so as much as i love the house and
i love all the worldly possessions
my ego is tied up in my ability to learn
and my willingness to suffer like if you
really want to know what makes me an ego
maniac it's those things so why do i do
an 11 hour q a because i know nobody
else can do it so and i just like every
minute that passes i'm getting more and
more arrogant about it and feeling great
and it's not like an ugly arrogance it's
like a fun arrogance of belief in myself
so
i'm going to go to them with a scary
detailed plan about the way that i'm
going to help their company it is not
[ __ ] it's not fluff i will really be
breaking down how i can help their
company so that i can go in and crush
that meeting and say look
you know what just happened i will own
my mistakes i won't [ __ ] i'll say this
is exactly what happened this is what i
learned this is why i'm not going to
make those mistakes again and this is
what i think that i can do for your
company this is why i think that i
deserve equity and i'm just going to go
down that list someone is going to say
yes i would first go down
everything that i want to do in the film
industry and if i don't get any bites
there then i would immediately go down
food nutrition
and then
literally guaranteed one of those two
areas somebody would bring me on as an
equity partner because my pitch would be
ridiculous to the point where if all
they did was take the meeting their
business would be better for it so i
hold myself accountable to that to real
results i would be the best interview
they ever had i would be trying to give
away every idea for their company that i
have because i know ideas are a dime a
dozen and all that matters is execution
so they will be in the meeting thinking
oh my god if this is what he's willing
to do just to get like a meeting with us
what would he be willing to do if we
actually brought him on and started
paying him something so and again i
would throw my ass financially in the
dirt and i would say look i'll work at
this for a year um and if lisa is
working and we can afford to eat i would
work for free and i would say i'll do
this for a year i've no problem what i
want is the equity and then i would work
my way back up so
yeah i actually get excited answering
that question because if you can't face
the loss of all your material
possessions with excitement it means
that you don't believe in your abilities
and you need to spend time focused on
your abilities what i really really
enjoy in fact i asked this of everybody
not everybody i've asked this many many
many times of people coming into the
company there are two choices before you
choice number one
you help let's say five people and they
all know who you are they would credit
you with transforming their life
at your funeral they would say this man
is the woman is the reason that i have
been successful plain and simple i owe
everything to them they're crying and
it's like you touch their lives you
touch their families lives
or
would you rather affect five million
people and none of them know who you are
now for me
it's not even a tough choice i would
rather affect the five million people
and they have absolutely no idea who i
am at scale is all i care about that's
it i am obsessed with doing things at
scale
i've actually never taken the time to
reflect on why i like that so much but
scale is what matters to me really
helping a lot a lot a lot of people that
is the thing that i'm really driven by
i'm convinced that while virtually
everyone you're ever going to meet they
will tell you that they want to do
something great with their life they'll
tell you that they've got big dreams
they've got plans and they're going to
make it happen
but they can't take criticism
they're not willing to look at what
they're doing wrong they're not willing
to admit that everything is their fault
but it's just a frame of reference and
if they would change that frame of
reference it would change
everything
and as tim grover said
the only difference between feedback and
criticism is how you hear it
understanding the brain understanding
how we process data understanding the
way that ideas get into your mind and
cause a chain reaction of emotions
if you can't figure that out and rise
above it and not become a victim of your
emotions not become a victim to people
saying something that knock you off your
confidence that make you feel insecure
that actually [ __ ] your ability to
perform because of how
you have decided
to hear something
and that moment of awakening that
breakthrough that is the realization
that you decide
what to focus on you decide what to hear
and what to take away from something
somebody can assail you they can attack
you they can
victimize you
but it's a choice as to whether or not
you play the victim
as winston churchill said criticism may
not be agreeable but it's necessary
it fulfills the same function as pain in
the human body it calls attention to an
unhealthy state of things
in the pursuit of greatness people are
still trying to avoid pain
if you really want to do something if
you really want to become somebody
then you've got to run headlong into
pain you've got to be looking for those
things that make you suffer you've got
to seek
out
the pain
you've got to seek out the things that
make you uncomfortable you've got to
want to hit that difficulty because it
is in those moments it is in that bit of
suffering it is in seeing what you are
not good at that is going to allow you
to become great and if you have to let
it fill you with rage to really
stand
in anguish
in order to force yourself to move
then stand in it
do whatever you need to do in order to
reach your goals and if that's the
motivation that you need then embrace it
and chase it
as tony robbins said the purpose of pain
is to move us into action
it's not to make us suffer
so in that anguish
in the
excruciating pain
find no suffering
see the joy in it welcome it like an old
friend and the day that you can welcome
your pain like an old friend because you
know like a friend it is taking you
where you need to go it is spurring you
into action it is pushing you to become
something and the process of rebirth my
friends
hurts
but whether you choose to suffer or not
is your choice
because remember tim's words
the only difference between feedback and
criticism is how you hear it the only
difference between pain and suffering
is how you frame it
so it's your choice
it's up to you how you're going to move
forward
but never
for one
second
forget
that it's a choice how do you deal with
pain do you reward yourself each day do
you seek instant gratification or do you
wait until you receive the pleasure you
actually want like achieving your
long-term goals um so it really depends
on what the pain is if it's an acute
pain i force myself to lean into it so
like when i'm at the dentist and it
really hurts then i'll actually open my
mouth wider to make sure that they get
like absolutely no subtle signal for me
that i'm in pain because i want them to
do whatever the hell they need to do no
matter how much it hurts and then i'm
rewarding myself in a
self-congratulatory way for not being a
wuss and for dealing with the pain when
it's in service of something that i
actually want to do and achieve
when it's a longer term like slower pain
like just being ultra disciplined not
eating the things that i want to eat
oftentimes i'll focus on the results to
keep myself really excited about what
i'm doing so with diet living forever
optimizing my cognition looking good
naked i'll stop and think about those
things and think about having a
discipline that other people don't have
and that gets me excited i'll also
reframe it so if i'm really dieting hard
i know that i'm going to be hungry for
hours and hours and hours on end days
and weeks stacking up i will welcome the
hunger like an old friend and i will
literally say in my head welcome hunger
my old friend i'm so glad that you're
here because it means that i'm
metabolizing fat so i do things like
that to really get my head in the right
place that i'm looking at something as
positive i'm looking at what it's
bringing me i'm focused on my goals i
know what i want
i'm focused on the identity of being the
kind of person that's willing to do that
and again it's self-congratulatory
uh because you're really stoked that
you've got the discipline and the
ability to do that stuff so learning how
to be self-congratulatory in a way that
isn't gross that doesn't make you an ego
maniac all of that stuff i think is
really really important and people need
to learn to do that to have compassion
have love for yourself to really be
stoked on who you're becoming um i think
is a really really important thing
you're the average of the five people
you spend the most time with that's just
true
and but now it's become so common to say
and it's like every instagram post that
i fear it's going to lose its meaning
who are you spending time with because
if you're spending time with people like
you you're spending time with people
like me i'm raising you up i'm just not
going to spend time with you
so it's like now if you get in a mix of
people like that who are like man we'd
love for you to raise up to this level
but if you don't it's fine but we're
just not going to spend time with you
all of a sudden that desire to belong to
something powerful that you can see is
going to lead you to your dreams and i
remember saying to my wife over and over
and over they are the surest path to my
success i don't know anything else i
just know if i can hang on to these guys
they're going to make me better
and so that was through all the years of
being embarrassed and developing
actually massive anxiety because i was
always behind i was always the dumbest
person on the phone i was always the
dumbest person in the room and it was
like
was i going to be willing to emotionally
go through that to get great and most
people can't so here's the thing now
imagine i'm not the only person they
said hey this is a startup you can have
any job you want they i saw
12 people maybe more come and go over
the years they just couldn't emotionally
deal with it and so i remember thinking
to myself why is it that i'm able to do
this and the answer was i could
self-soothe faster than anyone else so i
would get kicked in the face and i would
do something really dumb i'd be called
an idiot told how stupid i was and then
i'd just be like all right i need to
re-center and that just became my
obsession i need to be able to
emotionally get back to complete neutral
so fast that you don't even see a
register on my face how'd you do it how
do you do that literally practicing so
remember the same time i'm reading about
the brain voraciously i'm reading about
people that understand human behavior
i'm getting into cognitive science
neuroscience like really going into it
so i'm reading all this stuff going whoa
we're just a chemical processing plant
there are physiological hooks into these
chemicals so hey if you're mad scared
whatever but you force yourself to laugh
out loud
you will change your neurochemical state
and you literally your experience is the
neurochemistry so i was like whoa so i
could get i could be in a situation
where i'm being berated or i
legitimately mess up and it costs money
and it's like whoa that's on me and it
is nobody's bad but my own and i
realized that what most people do their
strategy is to deflect it it's your
fault it's not my fault yes so i started
thinking of this as a metaphor people
are throwing gold at me they're throwing
it really hard and i can put a shield up
and deflect it but then i lose that
piece of gold if i drop my shield and
just take the pain let it hit me in the
head then i bend down and go this thing
which is me being stupid there's a
lesson here and now i have this piece of
gold but the whole thing is i have to be
defenseless so i have to own it i have
to take it i can't fight if someone is
like this to this day if our team is
like hey there's something we need to
point out to you i'll do this
i square up to it i want them to know
like hey i want to hear it i want to
know like i want to be literally
physically open i'm not going to close
down i'm going to do everything i can to
square off to open myself so that they
know i'm receptive to the criticism
right because that's the nugget of gold
what i know is it's going to hurt it's
going to sting but if i can emotionally
recenter so fast you don't even see that
i went through something now i can just
process how do i take this information
you've given me and get better 80 of my
time i spend focused on the beautiful
things that i want to create the amazing
things the the mission that i'm on how i
want to help other people right i talked
about goals being exciting to you
and honorable so they uplift you and
other people
and i try to spend as much time as i can
there
and that's gotten me through a lot of
difficult times to think about the
people i'm trying to serve to think
about the way that i'm going to help
people we end every team meeting at
impact theory with a connection to our
communities whether it's playing a video
of somebody who's changed their life or
reading a letter that somebody's written
us about how
the content that we create has moved
them forward in some meaningful way and
they're beautiful and it's amazing it
feels so good
but
there are times
where i'm so fatigued
there's a great quote by vince lombardi
fatigue makes cowards of us all
and there are times where i'm so
fatigued
all the beautiful things in the world
are not enough to keep me going
and i'm just done i'm spent i'm in
i'm past the day david goggins 40
where he says when you think you're
broken and couldn't possibly go another
step you're only forty percent of the
way there okay the beautiful things that
get me past that hurdle
but when you're actually eighty percent
of the way there ninety percent of the
way there really close to being fully
spent
the thing that i lean on in that moment
is the dark side
the people that want me to fail
the people that are on my list
as i call it
there are people that have tried to
trip me up
that want to see me lose
that
come at me go behind my back whatever
and i put them on a list
and i never think about the list more
than 20 of the time because that's a
dark place to be
but when i'm really
tired
and i'm in danger of
cowardice
i think about those people
and it's an ugly energy
but damn
is it powerful
to say i'm not going to let them win
i will as david goggins says take their
souls
and it's really powerful
and it's one of those things that i
often get pushed back on because it is
ugly to say that i think about these
people and i think about destroying them
and beating them and outperforming them
in every way and dunking in their face
and doing better than them in life and
watching them
just get demolished by my performance
but it's motivating
and it works
now if you spend too much time there you
slide into bitterness you slide into
anger it's resentment it's all about
them
but man let me tell you
if you get that balance right 80 20
90 10
man it's
it's really profoundly powerful there is
a reason that evolution has given you
anger there's a reason that evolution
has given you rage there is a reason
that evolution has given you righteous
indignation as gandhi said strength does
not come from physical capacity it comes
from an indomitable will
we're talking about a man that took on
an empire
and he did it not by his physical
prowess but instead by not being willing
to be bowed or broken and at the end of
the day
that is something each one of us
controls that is something that each one
of us can build into ourselves we decide
whether or not we can be broken we
decide how far we're willing to go and
at the end of the day how far you're
willing to go how indomitable your will
really is comes down to one
simple
thing
do you believe in what you're fighting
for
are the hard times something that you're
willing to push through to persevere to
get to the other side because you
believe to the core of your being and
what you're fighting for and that is
something we all have to define for
ourselves that is something we all have
to build into the very core of our being
but most people just
stumble through life they
daydream through life they don't have a
plan they don't have something specific
that they're aiming at and because of
that when they hit an obstacle because
of that
when they hit something that pushes back
against them when they hit
an equally obstinate force
they break they bow they crumble
because they don't have that thing
that they're willing to fight for they
don't have that burning ember inside of
them that is dictating everything that
they do and because of that they're
never going to be able to get on the
other side of that obstacle because of
that life is going to stop them because
of that
every time that they try to create
momentum in their life something stops
them but it's not the thing on the
outside that stops them it's the lack
of something on the inside and as
winston churchill said
if you're going through hell keep going
but the only way that you're going to be
able to persevere through that the only
reason that you're going to have that
thing inside of you that demands that
you keep going is it you believe in that
thing if you've built something up in
your life
that you'd be willing to die for
and you live for it
when you construct that at the center of
your soul then you're going to have the
tenacity to push through then you will
see that you are not defined by your
physical prowess at that moment you will
understand
what gandhi was trying to say
that each and every one of us
will be made
by what we come to stand for each and
every one of us will be constructed
of our will
the things that we're able to do will be
defined by that so when you take the
time to build something
build the strength of conviction
that is what will see you through help
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want to learn the
7 habits of highly productive people
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there he looked at me
and he said what are you talking about
well i said you accomplished more in a
short period of time than anybody i've
ever seen and i've never seen the guy
rushing i never seen him even walking
fast